hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner taten welt
oder eigentlich herzlich willkommen in
meiner kochwelt heute geht es nämlich
mal wieder ein herzhaft gericht und zwar
habe ich ab und zu immer mal wieder lust
auf was schnelles auch was einfaches und
dann greife ich auch gerne mal auf
lüfter blätter zurück und zwar habe ich
jetzt ein leckeres rezept für so kleine
gerollte korrekt sagt man eigentlich
viele kennen sie wahrscheinlich
frittiert als zigarren börek oder sarah
beck sagt man auch dazu und ich noch
heute die version aus dem ofen und zwar
werde ich meine kleinen sarah beck also
die gerollten barrick film mit einer
leckeren spinat und käse füllung aber
natürlich zeige ich euch auch ein paar
alternativen und ihr könnt sie auch
immer fühlen wie ihr wollt
ich werde die teig blätter fertig
benutzen weil es einfach schnell gehen
soll
aber ich kann euch auch irgendwann mal
zeigen wie man lüfterblätter selber
machen kann und ich will jetzt einfach
mal sagen ich zeige euch die zutaten und
startete mit dem rezept klammeraffe wie
schon gesagt nehme ich jetzt einfach
fertigen teig blätter und zwar sieht es
ganz so aus
die gibt es im typischen supermarkt zu
kaufen aber auch schon in ganz vielen
supermärkten mit logos regel netto und
so weiter und das netz 360 gramm
und dies sind bereits in dreiecke
geschnitten das heißt es im jufa blätter
die rund ausgerollt war und dann wurden
sie bereits in dreiecke geschnitten
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier einfach
eine erleichterte arbeit für die füllung
werde ich diese zutaten nehmen ich habe
hier 200 gramm frisch pilates
neben spieler habe ich schon gewaschen
und trocken geschleudert hier habe ich
einen weichkäse und zwar ist es so ein
türkischer vater
die nämlich immer ganz gerne und davon
nämlich so ein halbes rasch das sind
etwa 120 gramm
ich habe eine zwiebel 1 esslöffel
tomatenmark und einen esslöffel paprika
mag das bindet sich auch ganz oft wenn
ich was türkisches machen und zwar gibt
es auch einfach in so gläsern oder dosen
auch im supermarkt zu kaufen eben bei
den türkischen oder international sachen
oder eben im türkischen supermarkt ich
hab hier noch einen halben teelöffel
gummi also kreuzkümmel wenn ihr das
nicht wollt könnt ihr das auch weglassen
im typischen heißt es kinder und ich
werde etwas pfeffer benutzen
datenblätter fertig sind und auch
relativ trocken sind denn die binde gar
nicht groß sein sonst würden sie eher in
der packung schimmelt werde ich diese
frau blätter bestreichen und zwar habe
ich hier ein ei das habe ich bereits
geteilt und zwar weg zum späteren
bestreichen verwenden und das eiweiß
werde ich hier benutzen mit 50
milliliter medium das ganze vermischen
und damit die blätter vor dem aufrollen
bestreichen und nach dem aufrollen werde
so michalke bestreite und mit
schwarzkümmel bestreuen da könnt ihr
auch sesam nehmen oder einfach das ganze
weglassen meine triebel habe ich jetzt
bereits geschält und bis jetzt in kleine
stücke würfel
das geht mit einem messer oder einfach
mit dem alligator
da stecke ich einfach die hälften rein
und es entstehen ganz kleine zwiebel
würfelchen diese geb ich damit etwa zwei
esslöffel olivenöl in einer pfanne und
dünnste sehen etwa 23 minuten glasig und
gäbe anschließend dann den spinat
komplett mit dazu und ihr seht auch dass
spinat hat ein sehr großes volumen aber
er fällt gleich in sich zusammen
wenn der deckel drauf ist einfach 34
minuten stehen lassen und dann kurz
umrühren und dann seht ihr auch wie es
so langsam in sich zusammenfällt wenn er
dann komplett geschrumpft ist geben wir
noch tomatenmark paprika mag und das
gehört dazu und würzen noch mit etwas
pfeffer nach und so ist die füllung auch
schon fertig und ich kann den käse
vorbereiten
da nehme ich einfach ein halbes rädchen
schneit es ab und den rest kann ich
wieder zurück in die dose geben kann sie
verschließen und in den kühlschrank
stellen
zum bestreichen verquere ich das eiweiß
mit einer gabel und gebe die milch dazu
und verquere es weiter am besten geht es
aber mit dem schneebesen und schloss es
kurz an der seite stehen
den käse brüssel ich jetzt noch in meine
füllung hinein die iris abgekühlt ist
und verrühren und dann habt ihr auch
schon alle vorbereitungen getroffen
ich nehme jetzt meine lüfterblätter und
legt sie auf einen großen teller und so
könnt ihr dann auch richtig gut arbeiten
wenn ihr alles einfach in der umgebung
habt mit einem silikon pinsel
bestreichen desktop mit der milch
mischung damit es schön feucht wird gäbe
dann zwei teelöffel von der füllung
darauf und verteile die füllung so dass
es eben etwas länglich verteilt ist aber
an den rändern jemals 3 cm platz ist die
seiten hab ich jetzt rechts und links
ein und falte sie einfach etwas damit
sie auch so liegen bleiben und klappe
dann unten die seiten auch noch mal ein
damit es oben nicht so hässlich aussieht
und rolle jetzt von oben nach unten
relativ fest zusammen und drücke die
spitze oben runter und wenn das nicht
klappt nehmen sie einfach noch mal den
pinsel bevor ich das ein bisschen und
legen es auf dem backblech und so weil
ich jetzt alle juchu blätter bis die
füllung aufgebraucht ist und diese
füllung reicht es nicht für die
komplette newsletter ich habe jetzt aber
auch insgesamt nur zwölf oder 15 jufra
blätter geräusch
und als alternative könnt ihr als
füllung zum beispiel auch nur den
vierter käse nehmen und etwas petersilie
hinein schneiden oder ihnen
beispielsweise etwas schenken ich habe
jetzt hier passt dass man das ist
türkischer schicken mit etwas knoblauch
geschmack und darüber gebe ich dann
etwas gouda oder wie hier einen kaffee
ist und den könnt ihr einfach in
streifen zurechtschneiden darzulegen und
da sind eure kreativität keine grenzen
gesetzt
dann könnt ihr das eigelb verrühren und
hier gebe ich auch noch ein bisschen von
meiner mischung mit rein damit es etwas
flüssiger wird und bestreichen so meine
jungs carol zum schluss betreue ich sie
dann noch mit dem schwarzkümmel nach dem
backen sehen die barrick so ausgebacken
habe ich sie bei 220 grad für etwa 15
bis 20 minuten bis sie eine schöne
goldbraune kruste haben und dann dürfte
sie auf einem teller servieren und
beispielsweise mit einem leckeren baum
salat oder tomaten salat servieren
im innern sehen sie dann so aus sind
also relativ hohen und haben eine
leckere füllung wie ihr gesehen habt
geht dieses rezept sehr schnell
und wenn man diese lüfterblätter immer
auf vorrat hat ist es auch immer mal gut
wenn man zum beispiel ganz überraschend
besuch bekommt oder man einfach mal
abends lust auf so einen stack hat und
die barrick schmecken auch kalt sehr gut
schmecken auch am nächsten tag noch sehr
gut und da sie im ofen zubereitet werden
sind sie auch nicht so sehr
kalorienreich wie die die frittiert
werden
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall noch
ganz viel spaß beim backen und beim
zubereiten und das rezept gibt es auch
sorten welt.de und samira zeigt jetzt
noch kurz in lippenstift
jetzt sind einfach schön aus ist er
richtig hübsch aus schöner samstag in
nächsten mal richtig schön kommen
wasserfarben mal okay ich mache das auch
immer mal ganz gerne so dass sich diese
kleinen
mit vor ort
die nachbarn haben fertig gebaut wie x10
hat geht es ziemlich schnell man kann zu
verfassen
mein kopf was ist heute los jetzt
stattete explodiert und natürlich